hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to final nights 3 now this
is a five nights at freddy's fan game
but this is just a demo I don't know if
I'm gonna be playing the full game and
I'm not gonna be going back and playing
1 and 2 of this series but a lot of you
guys said that this one was very well
made and I'm not opposed to playing
these five nights at Freddy's fan games
hello oh hey my nod for M I'm on up
pressing on the right area yeah well
there we go
okay so I don't want to make a habit of
playing too many of these but I want to
give credit where credit is due because
I do like indie horror developers I do
like indie game developers in general
and I like to see what people can create
of these things and see what unique spin
and people said that this one had a bit
of new creativity to it so we're gonna
see exactly what they mean by that very
soon
what what was it oh I'm in an Ambu whoa
whoa nicely done Oh Oh I'm being wheeled
in on a gurney
well I had no idea about this I've been
through this one too many times in my
life if you asked me wait how many times
how many times have I won wheeled in on
a gurney into a hospital because once
for burning my fingers those once when I
was about to get my tumor removed there
was another time ah when I passed out
and I can't drink anymore that's why
okay those two I think about three times
let's see hello it's me your best friend
to survive use these tips you must sleep
to progress no sleeping if Reapers are
in scare away pop and man when he's
closest clothes closet close door when
my friend is closest sleep tight
your time is not up yet fredbear thanks
buddy
that doesn't reassure me in any capacity
but I'm gonna see what it can happen
okay
Oh night one now this is just the demo
and once again when the full game comes
out I don't think I'm gonna be doing a
full playthrough of this I'm gonna save
my next full playthrough of a five
nights at Freddy's game when sister
location comes out and holy [ __ ]
whoa whoa what hell okay I don't know
the controls so I paw I'm gonna die
I can already predict it I'm gonna die
what the hell do I do do I not even need
the mouse okay Mouse [ __ ] that what do I
do
I don't know whoa whoa hey hi what do I
I don't know what to do oh god I can't
go on my bed what do I do about that
hi what are you doing outside the window
you clip creepy creep clearing in oh god
how do I scare away puppet man I don't
know I don't know the controls I'm
pushing lots of buttons please don't
murder me [ __ ]
ah he's getting closer Hey ah [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ]
hi I judged I'll be with you in a second
I know that for a fact
do I need to click anywhere is that what
I need to do hi how's it going I'm just
gonna stare death in the face cuz I got
no other alternative oh you got a lovely
smile I love the way your shoulders all
come up into a Batman symbol very good
oh god I'm dead I'm dead I how's it
going hi okay
game over I'm dead I don't know how to
play
how do you play how do you play I don't
know how to play okay all right I'm not
gonna use that as an excuse I'm gonna go
figure out the controls I'll be right
back
all right so I couldn't figure out what
exactly I was supposed to do I went to
the website I went in the games I I
don't know the controls so I'm gonna
there's gonna be a lot of
experimentation going on here
okay these do nothing that does nothing
that does nothing mouse buttons do
nothing oh wait whoa wait what was that
what did I do
where did I go where did I go where am I
where okay
mmm back up okay what am i doing ah
you're back oh [ __ ] [ __ ] man how do i I
don't know what I'm supposed to be doing
why can't I go forward now what what
oh ah gah [ __ ] me come on do something
come on pull away take my hand
follow me come on follow me I'm gonna
die again that's just what's gonna
happen cuz I can move Annie is that
something yeah seems like something any
good hi
okay [ __ ] me then alright I'm [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
oh I'm Fox yeah yeah
okay I got you you didn't get me I got
you Oh what what am i doing what am i
doing what am i doing what's happening I
don't know what's happening is this
relating to sleeping is this good I
don't know I can't I can't do anything I
guess this is good I think I'm not under
central place right here so weird I'm
here so weird today okay anyway I don't
know what's happening I don't know why
is happening I don't know what's
supposed to be happening I'm not ever so
sure about anything [ __ ] me then okay
lightning you gonna spook me huh that's
one intimidating clock right there
a great big clock coming to that are you
good son I can't do anything up I'm
pressing buttons oh that ain't good
I got my defenses in maximum maximum
efficiency nobody better come at me
nobody Canali yay well I did something I
don't know what I did what did I do
what did I do jeez Jesus
all right their aggression
Rises no frickin joke nice grid paper by
the way I always appreciate a good grid
paper as a former engineering student I
like grid paper bouquet 92 for a demo I
didn't expect it to have more than one
night probably gonna have two nights I
don't know when the full game is gonna
be released or how many nights are gonna
be in the full game okay so if I hit
space here it sleeps but if I had space
again okay now it does something okay so
if I forward oh it is clicking oh it is
clicking hey hey stop that you stop it
now okay I don't understand don't know
and I'm supposed to do oh that's not
good
I do what the hell man this is so weird
if something's buggy with my game where
I can't click properly let me try one
more thing to adjust this I'll be right
back I want to make this work I really
do okay so I'm back in the game and I
changed it I had to tweak with the
settings of it so I'm gonna try to sleep
a little bit get up go out there and try
to figure out what the hell I'm supposed
to do so I'm gonna sleep till one
o'clock cuz I need my beauty rest
Markham who needs a lot of uterus cuz
I'm [ __ ] ugly anyway so wake up go out
there go over here whoo there we go
what is that what it I'm sunken
something on sucking the [ __ ] out of
this funky song ker that's a thunk oh
whoa what what was that can I have that
the whole time what what am i doing I
can't see you goddamn thing oh [ __ ] how
do I get out of this okay well that
ain't good
hello [ __ ] why did I go confront him
oh geez I didn't mean to do that [ __ ]
all right then give us another go ah
lose the hair fur that's floofy my floof
is getting floofy I wanna try this again
but cuz now I got it working now the
controls are actually working so I can
actually play the game I don't know what
happened to my flashlight it only
appeared for like two seconds and then
it completely off loaded alright
whatever their aggression Rises I don't
give a [ __ ] hey alright okay bye then
very good so what do I do about you now
ah well jeez did I scare him
then I smoked here by screaming in your
face and such I'm going back into bed
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
[ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm out I'm out [ __ ]
I'm out I'm outie I'm just gonna take a
nice nap no I'm gonna bathroom no y'all
gone mad look good that ain't good
really I'm expecting something to pop
out but apparently nothing wants to say
hi to me open busty interrupt me I must
be so adorable when I sleep I should set
up a camera and watch myself as I
slumber I wouldn't be creepy
well I win again
what the heck
okay I don't know if I'm just getting
lucky or something horrible is about to
happen to me wow that was it hang on I'm
going back in oh go back in because
something ain't right here there's
something going on the flashlight is not
working properly I do not know what's
happening so it's starting over from the
beginning so I really want to see what
is going on who that I don't even know
who's in here it's like some weird
version of the puppet outside so guys
stick figure plumping the scare puppet
cuz he's a scarecrow puppet alright
whatever
so there's three main away so what do I
do about you
ah hello goodbye so what do I do who's
such it pop out and say hi cuz holy [ __ ]
oh that there's something there hello
yeah alright thank you
shut that on your hand please still in
there alright you're gone what do I do
about is there anything in this okay
well that ain't good so what happens do
I need to go on my bed huh go in the bed
well the bed go over the bed okay did
that take care of the thing can I see it
shadows in the darkness I think it's
gone probably yes it's in the room [ __ ]
oh god damn it why I thought the door
was open there for a second okay that
ain't good Kabam
slap it on your fingers that's what you
okay alright I guess I'm dead all right
so I have a moderate understanding of
this game what I get went into it it was
very confusing maybe because I haven't
played the first two I don't know the
mechanics fully well but it's a bit
interesting in that there seems to be a
lot going on but it's a little
convoluted as to what's what's it's all
about I I do appreciate the darkness but
there's also so much darkness that I
don't even know what the environment I'm
in so there's some things that I would
personally change but that doesn't mean
that it's not good because
I don't know the whole series so this
was final nights it seems pretty good
it's actually well made displaying the
Unreal Engine so it graphically a little
bit better as far as the shadows and
lighting goes modeling you know that's
up to the game developer and how much
works he wants to put in there now many
stock assets whatever that's not
important but this was final night so
I'll leave the opinions up to you guys
let me know what you thought of it in
the comments down below I think it was
pretty good it was a little convoluted
but maybe a little bit of confusion is
actually not a bad thing it wasn't as
scary as some of the other five nights
at Freddy's fan games that I played in
the past but then again I don't think it
emphasized as much on jump scares I
think it was more about the dread and
seeing your enemies coming closer but
who knows so anyway thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye